Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, seis,
siete, ocho, nueve y cero.
Con solo estos 10 símbolos, escribimos
cualquier número racional imaginable.
¿Pero por qué estos símbolos
en particular?
¿Por qué 10?
¿Y por qué los colocamos
de la manera que lo hacemos?
Los números han sido un hecho de la vida
a lo largo de la historia documentada.
Los primeros humanos contaron animales
quizá en un rebaño o miembros de la tribu
usando partes del cuerpo
o marcas de registro.
Conforme aumentaba la complejidad de
la vida y el número de cosas que contar,
estos métodos ya no eran suficientes.
Por eso, con el desarrollo
de las civilizaciones surgieron
maneras de registrar números más grandes.
Muchos de estos sistemas,
como el griego,
el hebreo,
y los números egipcios,
eran solo extensiones
de marcas de registro
que añadían símbolos para representar
mayores magnitudes de valor.
Cada símbolo se repetía tantas veces
como fuera necesario y se sumaban.
Los números romanos agregaron otro giro.
Si un número aparecía antes
de otro de mayor valor,
se restaba en vez de sumar.
Pero incluso con esta innovación,
todavía era un método engorroso
para escribir grandes números.
Un sistema más útil y elegante
hacía uso de la notación posicional.
Los sistemas numéricos anteriores debían
plasmar muchos símbolos repetidamente
e inventaban un símbolo nuevo
para cada magnitud más grande.
Un sistema posicional podía
reutilizar los mismos símbolos,
asignándoles diferentes valores
según su posición en la secuencia.
Varias civilizaciones desarrollaron
la notación posicional por su lado,
como los babilonios,
los antiguos chinos,
y los aztecas.
En el siglo VIII, los matemáticos indios
habían perfeccionado tal sistema
y durante los siguientes siglos,
comerciantes árabes, conquistadores
y eruditos, los difundieron en Europa.
Era un sistema decimal o de base 10,
que podía representar cualquier número
con solo 10 glifos únicos.
Las posiciones de estos símbolos
indican diferentes potencias de 10,
empezando por la derecha y aumentando
conforme avanzamos hacia la izquierda.
Por ejemplo, el número 316
se lee 6x10^0
más 1x10^1
más 3x10^2.
Un avance clave de este sistema,
que fue desarrollado por los
mayas de forma independiente,
fue el número cero.
Sistemas de notación posicional más
antiguos que carecían de este símbolo
dejaban un espacio en blanco en su lugar,
haciendo difícil distinguir
entre 63 y 603,
o 12 y 120.
La comprensión del cero tanto como
valor y como marcador de posición
hizo de esta notación algo
confiable y consistente.
Por supuesto, es posible usar
10 símbolos cualesquiera
para representar los números
de cero a nueve.
Durante mucho tiempo,
los glifos variaron por región.
La mayoría de los estudiosos
concuerdan en que los dígitos actuales
evolucionaron de los usados al norte
de África en la región del Maghreb,
en el Imperio árabe.
Y en el siglo XV, lo que ahora conocemos
como el sistema numérico hindú-árabe
reemplazó a los números romanos
en la vida cotidiana
y se convirtió en el sistema
numérico más usado en el mundo.
Pero ¿por qué el sistema hindú-árabe,
junto con tantos otros,
usan la base 10?
La respuesta más probable
es la más simple.
Eso también explica por qué los aztecas
usaron base 20 o un sistema vigesimal.
Pero también son posibles otras bases.
Los números babilónicos eran
sexagesimales, o de base 60.
Mucha gente piensa que una base 12,
o sistema duodecimal,
sería una buena idea.
Como el 60, el 12 es un número altamente
compuesto que se puede dividir en dos,
tres,
cuatro,
y seis,
lo que lo hace mucho mejor para
representar fracciones comunes.
De hecho, ambos sistemas aparecen
en nuestra vida cotidiana,
desde cómo medimos los grados y el tiempo,
hasta mediciones comunes,
como una docena o una gruesa.
Y, por supuesto, la base 2,
o sistema binario,
se usa en todos nuestros
dispositivos digitales,
aunque los programadores usan base 8
y base 16 para una notación más compacta.
Así que la próxima vez
que uses un número grande,
piensa en la enorme cantidad capturada
en estos pocos símbolos,
y fíjate si se te ocurre alguna
manera diferente de representarlo.